Romania in the late 1930s was not in an
enviable position it had rapidly grown
after victory in the first world war and
now incorporated many new territories
from its vanquished neighbors they also
nabbed this land could BES Arabia from
the collapsing Russian Empire during its
Civil War these neighbours Hungary in
the Soviet Union wanted these
territories back of particular concern
was this area within Transylvania which
had a large Hungarian population
problems really began for Romania after
the Third Reich in the Soviet Union's on
the molotov-ribbentrop pact in 1939
within this pact was a secret protocol
which designated that the Soviet Union
had a right to these lands could
Bessarabia and Bukovina On June the 26th
1940 the Soviet Union sent an ultimatum
to Romania give us these lands or we'll
invade the government conceded because
they knew that this was a war they
couldn't win and in the end the USSR
annexed this territory you see the
Hungarians now smelled weakness and so
decided that it was time for them to
press their claims to Transylvania
Hungary wanted it all Romanians response
was no one talks between the two
collapsed enter stage left the Germans
led by Adolf Hitler who demanded that
the situation be mediated Hungary led by
miklós horthy was pretty happy with this
since over the past few months Germany
had rewarded it with some of its former
lands back the Romanians really didn't
want to give up any more land but they
also really didn't want to fight the
Hungarians as such the Romanians offered
up this land northern transylvania to
hungary on the condition that the axis
promised to protect the country's
remaining borders this was all agreed on
August the 30th 1940 and thus Romania x'
borders were a lot smaller
demonstrations broke out across the
country which notably included the iron
guard also called the Legion which was a
fascist adjacent movement general ion
antonescu who was backed by the Legion
was invited to become prime minister by
King Carol on the 5th of September and
after taking up the post he demanded the
abdication of the king the next day
Karol thus fled to Switzerland taking a
bunch of gold with him and his son
Michael was crowned king but only held
ceremonial powers the rise of the Iron
Guard in Romania is often seen as a Nazi
backed coup which turned the country
into a puppet state to put it simply
this wasn't the case and the German
government urged Antonescu not to remove
the King since they were unsure about
him so remember when I said that Germany
would guarantee the integrity of Romania
x' borders about that on september the
7th bulgaria demanded that they be given
southern to brugge a germany backed this
claim in romania yet again had to yield
on November the
twenty-third Antonescu formally signed
up to the tripartite pact to became a
formal member of the axis why well
despite having territory ripped away
from his country three times with German
agreement antonescu needed to preserve
Romanian independence neutrality was no
guarantee since Romanian oil reserves
were too strategically important
how about siding with the Allies Britain
was a continent away and to be frank
look how Poland had fared and as for
Stalin well let's just say that was a
pretty firm no besides Hitler used
territorial rewards as a way of keeping
the axis together and made it clear that
if Romania made a major contribution to
the coming war with the USSR they would
get their territory back plus more thus
it's pretty clear that Romania is
joining of the axis wasn't based on
ideology but simply a desire to survive
I hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching and a special
thanks to all of these patrons you see
on screen for their generosity in
supporting the show and a particularly
special thanks to James Bissonnette
party boy Coe Ozark a flash Rob
Waterhouse Chris wicker Michael Reynolds
Thomas McGill Gustav Swan
Winston Cawood Skye Chappell the
amusement park Ives Adam Harvey and
lastly rafail